So we've touched on Optimization--
the notion that you could take part of one Abstract Syntax Tree
and replace it with something else, in order to make the program faster
or use less power.
The cardinal rule of Optimization was:
You can't change the meaning of the program.
You have to respect the formal semantics
or at least, that's what I've always told you.
But what if we break that law?
What if we want to change the meaning of a program?
For example, what if your program currently has a bug
and I want to change it so that the bug isn't there?
What if I want to fix your program--
Optimize it so that it is more correct,
instead of being faster?
I've worked on just this sort of research project.
We call it Evolutionary Program Repair.
It involves using genetic algorithms or genetic programming--
computational analogs of Real World biological processes,
like Crossover and Mutation.
We maintain a population of candidate programs that may fix your bug--
just like you can imagine a population of animals on an island
and then survival of the fittest allows some of them to stay,
and the rest to die out.
If you're interested in this sort of research--
I affectionately call it Building Skynet
because we're building a program that builds other programs--
there should be links below.
But one of the things that I want you to take away
is that the concepts that we're covering in this class--
notions like Abstract Syntax Trees
or replacing one expression with another--
can be used in different contexts, to great effect.
It just requires creativity to know when you can bend the rules
without breaking them.
That creativity is the essence of engineering.